one of my it's hard to pick my favorite
of your
um biographies but Einstein I mean you
really paint a picture of another
I don't want to call him a misfit but a
person who doesn't necessarily have a
standard trajectory through life of of
success
so absolutely and it's that's extremely
inspiring uh I don't know exactly what
question to ask there's a million well
I'll talk about the misfit for a second
because you know we talked about
Leonardo being that way you know
Einstein's Jewish in Germany at the time
when it starts getting difficult uh he's
slow in learning how to talk and he's a
visual thinker so he's always
daydreaming and imagining things
the first time he applies to the Zurich
Polytech because he runs away from the
German
education system because it's too much
learning by wrote
he gets rejected by the Zurich Polytech
now it's the second best school in
Zurich and they're rejecting Einstein I
tried to find but couldn't the name of
the admissions counselor at the apology
yeah like you rejected Einstein uh and
then he doesn't finish in the top half
of his class and once he does and he
goes to graduate school they don't
accept his dissertation so he can't get
a job he's not teaching it he even tries
about 14 different high schools
gymnasium uh to get a job and they won't
take him so he's a third class examiner
in the Swiss patent office in 1905.
third class because they've rejected his
doctoral dissertation
and so he can't be second class of first
class because he doesn't have a doctoral
degree and yet he's sitting there in the
stool in the patent office in 1905 and
writes three papers that totally
transform science
and if you're thinking about being
misunderstood or unappreciated in 1906
he's still a third class Patrick in 1907
he still is it takes until 1909 before
people realize that this notion of the
theory of relativity might be correct
and it might upend all of Newtonian
physics how is it possible
for three of the greatest papers in the
history of science to be written in one
year by this one person is there some
insights wisdoms you draw plus he had a
day job as a patent examiner and there's
really three papers but there's also an
addendum because once you figure out
quantum theory and then you figure out
relativity and you're understanding
Maxwell's equations and the speed of
light
uh he does a little addendum that's the
most famous equation in all of physics
which is E equals m c squared so it's a
pretty good year
it partly starts because he's a visual
thinker and I think it was helpful that
he was at the patent office rather than
being the acolyte of uh some professor
at the Academy where he was supposed to
follow the rules and so at the patent
office that doing devices to synchronize
clocks because the Swiss have just gone
on Standard time zones and swiss people
as you know tend to be rather you know
Swiss they care if it strikes the hour
in Basel or to do the same and burn of
the exact answer so you have to send a
light signal between two distant clocks
and he's visualizing what's it look like
to ride alongside a light beam he says
well if you catch up with it if you go
almost as fast it'll look stationary but
Maxwell's equations don't allow for that
and he said he's making my palm sweat
that I was so worried and so he finally
figures out because he's looking these
devices to synchronize clocks that if
you're traveling really really fast
which looks synchronous to you or
synchronous eyes to you is different
than for somebody traveling really fast
in the other direction and he makes a
mental leap that time
that the speed of light is always
constant but time is relative depending
on your state of motion so it was that
type of out of the box thinking those
leaps that made 1905 his miracle year
likewise with Musk
I mean
after General Motors and Ford everybody
gives up on electric vehicles
to just say I know how we're going to
have a path to change the entire
trajectory of the world into the era of
electric vehicles and then when he comes
back from Russia where he tried to buy a
little rocket ship so he could send a
experimental Greenhouse to Mars and they
were poking fun of him and actually sped
on them at one point in a drunken lunch
this is very fortuitous because on the
ride back home on the plane on the you
know Delta Airlines flight he's like
doing the calculations of how much
materials how much metal how much fuel
how much would it really cost and so
he's visualizing things that
other people would do would just say is
impossible it's what Steve Jobs's
friends called the reality Distortion
field and it drove people crazy it drove
them mad but it also drove them to do
things they didn't think they would be
able to do